just being the place where we're driving
down the street and everyone's in
question yeah we really want to meet
yeah we're on a mission that's our
mission basically like and to make those
guys who met Jagger marathon or whatever
we are here to meet so said if you ever
see this would be probably Rome we think
you're a freaking genius got a pile on
Sunday and we've been bowling today
which was good fun and then we're gonna
go and hit the convention floor go to
your advances and one of the most sort
of interesting things I think for us has
been the has been the emergence of it in
America
yeah that's gathering popularity here
and it's each each time we come we sort
of notice a market difference in the
amount of attention exciting I like the
episodes their character based yeah the
ones that really get into the characters
and their relationships between those
three central people yeah I like those
ones I thought we're in the TARDIS comes
down the blue box there's something
about it you can use it anywhere and
it's it's it looks really cool when it's
like fully assembled yeah
so then inside is always weird cuz like
sometimes there's like a little toolbox
in there quite like I like it
yes sanctuary you like away from being
told what to do
in and you're in the dark yeah it's like
a it's like a birth pool yeah just like
a flirtation time
all of the pawns is nice yeah it is
imminent in the most exciting way pops
it's the best exit ever yeah
let's power sunglasses on oh wait oh now
we know we look really cool
yeah like no not at all right we've got
the same sunglasses yeah I know but you
guys should have chatted about this what
I could have liked it yeah partners in
time